audiences are headed back to raccoon
city and this time it'll be on the big
screen the original resident evil video
game has spawned an interactive empire
of nearly 30 entries if you add up
everything in its main series along with
the spin-offs and remakes its original
movie adaptation sprouted its own long
legacy including six total films
released between the 2002 original and
2017's resident evil the final chapter
each starring mila jovovich and each
trying to one-up its predecessors and
finding crazier ways to kill off
characters earlier this year netflix
released an animated series resident
evil infinite darkness and the streaming
service is also releasing a live-action
resident evil series starring lance
reddick sometime in the near future on
the big screen the franchise is going
back to the beginning rebooting itself
on screen in the upcoming resident evil
welcome to raccoon city writer director
johannes roberts promised ign this new
entry will take resident evil back to
its creepy lo-fi roots with dark
hallways jump scares and maybe even some
unstoppable killers bursting through the
walls here's what we know so far the
film is currently scheduled to be
released on november 24 2021 a few
months later than originally planned
thanks to the pandemic but that also
puts the film well clear of october's
traditional influx of horror fair
leaving that particular lane md for
resident evil unless ghostbusters
afterlife which comes out the week
before has a lot more scares than the
mini marshmallow men we've already seen
in keeping with its reboot timeline
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
will also see a host of new faces taking
on some of the classic characters from
the game and film series first and
foremost will be actress caesco dellario
taking on the role of series heroine
claire redfield scodillario is best
known for her work on the uk television
show skins as well as the 2011
adaptation of wuthering heights the maze
runners series and pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales where
claire goes her brother chris cannot be
far behind the older redfield sibling
will be played by robbie amell who
appeared in films the duff and the
babysitter as well as tv shows like the
tomorrow people upload and the flash
where he played firestorm hannah john
cayman best known as ghost in ant-man
and the wasp will play chris's partner
jill valentine tom harper of black sails
game of thrones and umbrella academy
fame will play series villain albert
wesker rounding out the cast are donald
logue neil mcdonough lily gao and avan
jojia whose casting as leon kennedy
proved controversial to some fans as
fans might guess from the cast of
characters it seems a new film will draw
mostly from the first two games in the
franchise resident evil and resident
evil 2 an igm report indicates that its
locations will primarily be the spencer
mansion featured in the first game and
the raccoon city police department from
the second the film is also reportedly
set in the year 1998 the same year
resident evil 2 was released for
playstation this makes sense since
mcdonough and gal's character william
berkin and ada wong were prominently
featured in the second game the official
sony pictures releasing log line focuses
mostly on its setting reading once the
booming home of pharmaceutical giant
umbrella corporation raccoon city is now
a dying midwestern town the company's
exodus left the city a wasteland with
great evil brewing below the surface the
tagline continues on to say when that
evil is unleashed the town's people are
forever changed and a small group of
survivors must work together to uncover
the truth behind the umbrella and make
it through the night but while we may
lack details about the exact plot and
how closely or not it might follow those
of the games we do know what the film is
setting out to do with its tone as
robert said in a featurette welcome to
raccoon city is a very faithful
adaptation of the resident evil games
this is where it all started sounds just
like 1998 how terrifying
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one